in my dams every day we got like dozens
of books like unsolicited foreign older
gentleman what is a misconception people
have about one maybe that it sort of
serves a narrow lane of like horny men
everyone's being something that they're
not someone's pretending I personally
had a great experience of online dating
and that a great guy not everyone does
very well on dating apps some of my
stronger qualities are how I make you
feel and that's not necessarily
something that can come through on a
dating app I feel like online dating
thing has really skewed how young men
and women especially look at
relationships but I think I'm open - I
would love to learn just to see what
kind of success that he had I am
anne-marie and I'm a stay-at-home mom my
name is Percy I'm 24 and I'm an actor
I'm Erik I'm 21 and I'm a student and I
have all social media stuff I'm Brittany
I'm 28 I'm a holistic healer and a yoga
instructor and Philip I am 24 and I'm a
director at Jubilee and I'm Kendra I'm
27 and the casting producer Jubilee
can I get my online dating on the left
and traditional dating on the right
dating apps are all about sex
uh I was a little hesitant to come up
here cuz I again I think it depends for
certain people but my generation a lot
of people just use it for hookups I was
hesitant to come up here too because I
don't think it's all about sex but I do
you think it's mostly about sides I
think it is harder to meet someone who
was on there genuinely to like find a
connection and get to know someone who
doesn't want that because for me
personally I want to wait to have sex
until marriage and I had a friend tell
me I was too wholesome and I was like I
was too wholesome and that's why I
wasn't getting any matches because I
wasn't like a showing cleavage and I
wasn't posting like there's trap
pictures I've been through it all just
turned a bumble henge even Facebook has
a thing now but a lot of times it's just
you know I'm gonna based off looks and
then you know it's one of those things
but I feel like I'll meet my my my
partner in person I have an idea for you
per se maybe I'll be a matchmaker I
start a business and I'll find like
really quality women for you and I
really quality I was on fourteen
different dating apps and everyone was
like well Kendra why don't you like go
on Christian mingle Christian mingle is
full of men who just want nice Christian
girls who are actually Christian and
it's just like going out on dates
normally with guys I would have just as
much pressure as I would online it's
just from an online perspective that's
not what I was looking for at the time
but when I was looking for that at the
time online is an easy way to find it
and this is just social media in general
is that you can get away with doing you
know you can be like hey baby oh I want
to do this and this to you in my damns
everyday we got like dozens of like
unsolicited foreign older gentlemen
yeah but I mean it's just like that's
the reality of the world we're in today
and like there is a large hookup culture
so of course it's gonna lead into online
dating but I don't think just because
it's online it's necessarily gonna lead
to more culture do you meet your
boyfriend I get a man one tinder you did
yes yeah we've been going out for like
four years now who lives over in
Philadelphia and yeah I've never
actually like gone on a date outside of
a dating app so I don't know based on
the people I've met I don't really feel
like there's ever been like an
expectation that it's about sex for me
the only expectation going into a dating
app is that you'll like get along with
the other person I mean I have platonic
friendships from people who I've like
met through apps like that were just
like didn't work out and like I've I
think that the reality is for a lot of
people part of being in a relationship
with someone is like sex so it's really
just like a matter of like thinking down
the line online dating perpetuates
discrimination
it's kind of discrimination that I'm
thinking of is good looks versus average
looks I feel like it sets a standard
that's not normal okay
you said looks yeah and I completely
agree with that a lot of times when I'm
elapsed it's always based off looks
first like I'm not even reading your bio
anything and I'm just being honest as
long as if you look good house white
right and then some girls take pictures
from up here and that's not really okay
can I say I'm taking this prompt from a
racial standpoint there's a lot of
racism and dating apps and that is just
the fact the founder of OkCupid released
a study back in 2014 where he made a
graph and collected people's preferences
and it showed that black women and Asian
men are the least preferred on dating
apps I've had guys when I was on dating
app say the most disgusting racist
things to me like let's play dress-up
like you're the slave and I'm the master
or like I've never I've never dated a
black girl before or like you're pretty
for a black girl just microaggressions
like that and it's disgusting and it
makes me feel like I'm less I don't
respond I absolutely don't respond you
don't deserve my attention after saying
something like that so I have the exact
opposite opinion of Kendra's where I
feel like online dating has put me in
front of people that I wouldn't normally
my fiance is Italian and he's never
dated a black girl before I love him
he's the love of my life and I met him
dating online and I don't think that we
would have met in real life with our
past crossing and I really apologize for
that it's like it's okay for people to
not like me in their head but once you
go ahead and send me a message saying
like let's do this or you like calling
me a name then that's like overt
discrimination and I definitely
understand that because I because I feel
like so often when people are like oh
what even when people say stuff like oh
I only date black women it makes me feel
like I'm less like why can't you just
like me because you think I'm beautiful
or because you think I have a good sense
of humor why can't you like me for basic
qualities in which you like other women
why do I have to be other because of the
color of my skin that's what bothers me
realistically dating apps don't
perpetuate you mean
stereotypes are starting out stereotypes
but you know discrimination because I
feel like you come on to a dating app
with your own preconceived notions of
people you come on and if you choose to
be racist or if you choose to act in a
certain way that was you as a person
already it's not because the dating app
you know I didn't mean but what do you
think about dating absolute dating apps
like OkCupid in the league have
preferences in which you can select race
- do you think they should be able to do
that
I don't think inherently there's a
problem with an app like catering to
what it thinks your preference it's odd
because people wouldn't use it if it
didn't give them what they were like
expecting to see or like wanting to see
it's hard to tell someone that they're
wrong for liking or disliking a certain
thing unless they're being like
outwardly hateful I mean what's the
difference I think discrimination and
preference is to different categories
having a preference and then
discriminating it should not be
intertwined but I think preferences
invite discrimination because if you
prefer something then a whole group of
people are discriminated against because
my love am I not allowed to know you I'm
not saying that you're not I do think
everyone kind of goes into dating apps
with a racial bias I cast a lot of
dating shows for Jubilee and will do
like versus one or t42 and the first
question I ask people is do you have a
preference of ethnicity and they always
say no and then a question later down
the line will be like can you describe
physically with that for what you're a
person that you're attracted to looks
like and they'll say things like blonde
hair blue eyes well traditionally white
people have blonde hair and blue eyes so
you do have like a racial preference you
know I have felt unsafe when meeting up
with a date
so when I was younger I was just scared
to go on a date because I have had bad
experiences when I was 11 years old I
was sexually molested by a basketball
coach in the communities so ever since
then it kind of put a bad connotation of
like I don't feel safe even when I did
start going out on dates I would have to
drive my own car I would let my friends
know like hey this is the person that
I'm going out with I send them my
location that kind of made me feel a
little bit safer I'm really sorry that
that happened to Brittney like that is
really unfortunate I can't imagine me
personally I don't think I've ever felt
unsafe because I always make sure that I
meet someone in a public space I always
make sure I tell at least one other
person where I'm going and who I'm
meeting with I also tell them what
dating gap I've had them on yeah and I
make sure to like set a time for them to
check in with me
you know I I've actually you know
believe it or not a good-looking guy
like me I've never been on a date you
know someone online yeah but I usually
get to know the person a lot before I
take that step because again there's a
lot of courage to to be even just acts
you know but again is everybody's
experience is different and I could see
why for you it would be such a hard
thing to cope with and I completely
understand honestly I feel like the
damage that we live in now everything is
totally accessible especially
information so we hear about all these
kidnappings and we hear about people you
know like young women not to say that it
doesn't happen to men but you know just
meeting up at people's houses to hook up
ah yes I'm like that is the most
dangerous thing in a place you know you
mean you can still be put in a super
dangerous situation I've had friends who
have met men online and found out after
a relationship that they that Matt was
actually married
traditional dating as well I mean that
can happen with someone that lives right
around the corner from you yeah but it
helps if you have your you know your
your family and friends your people with
you that know your background know the
the neighbor or know you know what I
mean it's like it helps a little bit it
doesn't keep things happening like like
what happened to you but it I think it
kind of minimizes it a little bit there
are like apps that have things both like
like like in like on tinder you can like
see how many degrees you are away from
someone so if they're like a 1st degree
[Music]
verification process is online where you
verify your Facebook or Instagram I'm
like okay if this person doesn't have
this many verifications I'm not even
responding online dating makes it harder
to commit to one person so I've been
with my current girlfriend for about a
year and we met on a dating app I don't
think it makes it harder to stay
committed but I do feel like it probably
makes it harder to decide on like the
initial commitment there's a portion of
time where we like still both had the
dating apps downloaded after we started
like dating and it wasn't like
considered exclusive yet and there's
just sort of this like thing in the air
where it was like well who's gonna like
delete that first feel like I have a
hard enough time picking my favorite
flavor at the ice cream store you know
what I mean and then like if I were like
dating now and I met you know a guy
online I would be like second-guessing
myself all the times like well what
about that guy from to two rows back I
could not disagree more I honestly feel
like it's not a choice you don't have to
it's what's difficult about it when you
love someone you're like okay what we're
sitting in the car together my fiance
and I we were sitting in the car
together both of our phones were okay
like delete this unsubscribe from this
like nothing was lingering like once
like I think it was like our second or
third date we were late for
to really give this a chance clear like
clear all that bad energy out like let
all that glow so that way you can fully
commit even if it doesn't work out give
that person a chance I agree with your
saying but like the one thing is like
I'm talking about like a step back from
there where it's like before you've like
decided to like have a conversation
about how you guys are together not
knowing who to like actually respond to
on a dating app so it ultimately led me
to finding my current relationship with
jibt which just makes me feel kind of
weird cuz it's like how I don't even
know like how I'm making the decision
I'm like who to respond to like there's
so many people coming in and out in the
real life to though there's so many
factors I feel like that play into who
you meet and who you decide to go out
with that no matter what but if you ever
all like congregated on to this one
inbox of like people who are just like
but I do think we have to speak about
that larger congregation of people who
don't commit because there's that
there's that net theory right of if
there's a net I'm going to be less
afraid to jump because I know something
is going to catch me I know that I'm
going to be saved so it's like I can go
into this and I can say I want to fully
commit to this but if we get into a
fight or if they smell bad or something
I there's an out like there's always
people who all we are always looking for
the exit sign and I think there's that's
a larger population of people than not
that's the reason why you have to commit
because I remember him mentioning that
even when him and his girlfriend were
starting to meet up with each other you
guys both had these dating apps still
downloaded on your phone for me it was
like okay I really like you I'm giving
this a chance deleted there is someone
out there for everyone I mean I know
this isn't a popular opinion but I do
believe there is one person for everyone
what I was seventeen for seven years I
wrote letters to my future husband I
would just write about how I you know
like I can't wait to meet him I can't
wait to like spend Christmases together
I would talk about the activities I
couldn't wait to do with him and like I
actually was planning on like writing a
letter until I hit and then giving it to
him like on our wedding night and the
whole I'm so corny guys
and I actually I actually ended up
ripping the journal up because I had the
advice of a therapist they had told me
that I am keeping him in these pages and
preventing him from manifesting in real
life and if I want him to come to me in
real life like I can't keep him in these
pages and so actually like when I was in
high school I wrote everything down and
then it all came to pass all of it every
thought you know all the things that I
wrote down that were my dreams
the key to manifestation is being able
to get it out of here
and put it in some physical form whether
it be speaking it or writing it so I
regret it now
you know for me coming into this I
wasn't I wasn't looking at it as me
against you because I do think this
getting both you know and it works and I
think at the end of the day it all just
comes down to effort and what you're
willing to put in because you can go
online you can do traditional but if you
only put in there 50% of the work and
you're not building yeah I feel like
many elements have to meet up no matter
for traditional dating or if your online
dating and that's it for you guys thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Laughter]